hello and welcome back to a20 special
relativity in this little video i want
to continue with my introduction and
talk about the research i'm interested
in
but this is not strictly on the topic of
special relativity
but you will see some of the influences
of my research in the class as well as
we move along
so what am i interested in and what i'm
working on i work on the large hadron
collider you see behind me here a
picture of the cms detector cms detector
is one of two omnipurpose detectors at
the large hadron colliders there's also
lhcb
and release two more dedicated
experiments
the large hotron collider collides
protons at the highest possible energies
in some units 13 tv terror electron volt
collision energy
collision happen around
40 million times per second in this
machine
when it's operational
um and we have made great progress in
understanding nature uh using this
machine in the last about decade uh the
large hadron collider started operating
in 2009
we are currently in a shutdown phase but
we hope to restart next year
with even higher center of mars energies
available
for for our studies
so why do we need a machine like this um
colliding particles at higher energies
allows us to probe the structure of
matter um like with the big microscope
and so we we can
look very deeply into into the structure
of the proton
at the very same time we can this
high center of mass energies and
collisions produce perhaps new particles
unexpected particles we will later see e
equal m c square
as a result of special relativity that
when you have enough energy you might be
able to produce a new particle of high
mass
and so that's kind of the holy grail and
what we're trying to do
and the other thing we do here is by
colliding protons and sometimes even
lead ions um
we are able to create a very hot and
dense form of matter
similar to
the environment
after the big bang and we are able to
study this this new form of of matter
let's see how
mars and mata are being built if you
take
the table in front of you and you start
looking in detail you start seeing
molecules and atoms
the atoms are built out of electrons and
the nuclei the nuclei itself is built of
protons and neutrons and if you look
more precisely drill deeply into the
structure you see that a proton
you know on the surface is built out of
quarks
up quarks to up quarks and a down clock
if you further investigate the structure
of the proton you see that
there's much more going on there's
gluons
particles holding the quarks together
and there's also bunches of quarks and
antiquarks this is by now well
understood
if you ask what is the mass of the
proton it's about one
giga electron volts or 938 mega electron
volts um but where does the mass come
from the mass of the proton comes in
parts of the mass from the mass of the
quarks but in most parts uh from
the
gluons or the
fields which holds the quarks together
that's kind of surprising but if you had
eight or two already you know that
there's energy stored in a field and
that energy again is equivalent to the
mass so
the
energy stored in the gluon field holding
the quarks together gives mass to the
proton and this works quite well there's
a theory which describes all of this
it's called qcd quantum chromodynamics
and you know if you with some assumption
you can calculate the masses of a bunch
of particles so this this plot here
shows the lightheartron spectrum which
can be calculated using the squishy
event
what i'm actually interested in
is the mass of elementary particles so
this
discussion so far uh was a brief
overview and how
composite particles like your table
becomes massive but how does the quark
itself acquire mass how does an electron
acquire mass or a neuron in ital
this picture here
shows you all known elementary particles
um we can put them in three boxes quarks
those are the particles the up quarks
and the dunk rocks we found in the
proton the electron
um
makes uh
together with the proton makes a
hydrogen atom
there's neutrinos those are called
electrons and then there's force carrier
and we just met the gluons but there's
also a photon the w and the z boson and
the w z both on they are themselves also
mass masses particles how do they
acquire mass
the answer was found passed about eight
years ago
with the discovery of the higgs boson a
new particle
and the underlying theory explains how
particles acquire mass
and so
basically solve right not quite so this
is really mysterious to see how
different the masses of those elementary
particles actually are you see this on
this logarithmic table here
again here our friends the down quarks
the up quark
and the electron
and if you compare this for example with
the heaviest known elementary particle
the top quarks you see many many orders
of magnitude different yes so how does
this actually work
and then you see some of the bosons the
force carriers are massive others like
the photon and the clue ones
are mass less
the answer to this was the higgs
mechanism
and a very simple explanation how the
the fix mechanism actually works for
fermions for those quarks of the
electron for example is given in this
cartoon
um so the idea is that
a field
fills all of space it's basically a
property of the vacuum and then you
travel as an elementary particle through
this
vacuum
you interact with this field
and the stronger you interact the more
drag you kind of get some sort of you
feel an inertia and this inertia is what
we we know as the mass of the elementary
particle
so there is an equivalence between how
strongly you couple to this
to the vacuum to the higgs field and
your mass and so a top quark is
coupled strongly to the sixth field
while an electron only so lightly
great um so we have understood
everything so we you know the question
is why do we uh still and you know
collide protons important at the lhc
um is there anything else to be
discovered
so it turns out that we have a very
sophisticated theory describes those
particles and their interactions
but this theory fails to explain the
observe all of the observations we have
in nature
and so that is kind of the driving force
behind
the experiment i'm conducting right now
and so for example we know that there's
dark matter when we look at the rotation
of stars in galaxies we find that they
don't behave
um as you would expect simply all based
on the distribution of matter in those
galaxies there must be something else
out there and that's what since it's not
visible it's called dark matter and
those dark matter
um
that dark matter could be a particle we
might be able to produce at the lhc so
that's an interesting
question
um also when we look out in the universe
we see a lot of matter you don't see a
lot of anti-matter so there must be
in the symmetry
behind between how matter and antimatter
is being produced
and so that is also not fully understood
yet
and then there's more question for
example
those neutrinos they're really really
light
you know on this leg scale i had a cut
off um and then the neutrino masses do
neutrinos acquire mars as an electron
does as a top quark does or is a
different mechanism
we don't know
um gravity is not even included in the
standard model and the fact that the
higgs boson was discovered at a specific
mass which is rather small is also a
little bit unnatural and so there is
this entire list of questions
and unresolved mysteries which we're
trying to uh to answer
and the way we do this is with big
cameras
so this is cms detector a similar
picture as behind me um it's a you can
think about it as a big camera looking
at the interaction of of the collision
of two protons and it starts off with
around this interaction region with the
pieces of silicon
which we use to track charged particles
going through
we put all of this in a magnetic field
and if
if you
listen to 802 already you know the
charged particle in magnetic field they
follow a curvature
and from the radius of the curvature we
can
um calculate the
momentum of those particles and then we
stop the particles in order to measure
the energy
so we do this in calorimeters and what
we use here is the lead tungsten
electromagnetic calorimeter and a second
calorimeter for particles which are
harder to stop
um so those are called hydronic
calorimeters and then the silver part in
the middle here
gives the cms detector it's its name
it's the as a solenoid it's a two-part a
3.8 tesla superconducting magnet and
then we have more detectors out there to
see
whether or not some particles might to
escape and we try to measure those as
well
there's another very nice picture after
opening the detector you see this silver
thing in the middle here is the pipe in
which the protons zoom through the
detector and are brought into this car
and to collision in the very center part
of it
all right and then we take those
pictures here's one and this is a very
famous one it's a higgs candidate event
where the higgs boson might have decayed
into two z bosons and then the z bosons
themselves decayed again
into a pair of electrons shown here and
a pair of muon here
and then we can use
those individual particles to
reconstruct the property of the exponent
here's another candidate where there's
two photons being reconstructed and
again those two photons can then be used
in order to reconstruct for example the
mass of the particle which is the origin
first two protons
so we have done this for the last years
and
i collected quite some data and if we
look at the entirety of the data we can
make this plot here and what this plot
here shows
is the mass of the particle
and the coupling of the particle to the
hex field
and what you see there is a linear
relationship in this log-log plot
between those two
and that
gives us some confidence that the
elementary particle like a muon here
like a
[Music]
tau laptop here like the top quark here
they acquire mass through the coupling
of the higgs field
and so there's this linear relationship
the correspondence between mass and
coupling to the x field
great so we have this all together and
it gives us a complete theory again
there's a large number of open mysteries
and questions we'd like to to answer
and the way i look at this is a little
similar to you know the exploration of
for columbus so what we are trying to do
is we go to higher and higher energies
to higher and higher intensities to find
out whether or not we find first hints
of something new and unexploited
so we made this discovery we made the
discovery of the higgs boson but whether
or not this particle is really the higgs
boson is still out there
we are trying to measure it's this more
and more position
maybe we find deviations from its
expected properties to the ones we
observe similarly christopher columba
when columbus when he sailed off from
spain
he
tried to
reach the indies or asia
and in his lifetime he never figured out
that he didn't actually accomplish this
and similarly maybe we have discovered a
new project which helps us to understand
you know more about the inner structure
of particles
you